- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Parlement hebdo".
L'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité parlementaire,
à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat.
Cette émission
est consacrée au projet
de loi immigration,
actuellement
en suspens au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Nous sommes justement
avec Annie Genevard.
Bonjour,
et merci beaucoup
d'être sur le plateau
de "Parlement hebdo".
Vous êtes députée
Les Républicains
du Doubs, secrétaire
générale du parti LR,
et vous siégerez au sein
de la commission mixte paritaire
qui aura la mission
de trouver un accord
sur le projet de loi immigration.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Sept députés
et sept sénateurs
vont tenter
de se mettre d'accord
sur un texte
de loi.
En cas de désaccord,
le texte sera abandonné.
Emmanuel Macron
veut résoudre
cette crise avant Noël.
Les députés ont refusé
de débattre
du projet de loi,
alors la négociation
se fera sur la base
du texte proposé
par la majorité
de droite du Sénat.
La restriction
et la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'Etat
est une ligne rouge
pour la majorité présidentielle.
Le député insoumis
Ugo Bernalicis sera privé
de la moitié
de son indemnité
après son altercation
en examen
des lois.
- Kathia Gilder:
Lundi 11 décembre,
l'Assemblée
nationale a accepté
une motion
de rejet déposée
par les Ecologistes.
Cela a eu pour effet d'interrompre
immédiatement l'examen
du texte en séance
publique et d'infliger
une lourde défaite
au gouvernement.
- Lundi, c'est le scénario
catastrophe
pour le gouvernement.
- Pour: 270.
Contre: 267.
Ce projet de loi est rejeté.
- Une motion
de rejet préalable
est rejetée.
C'est la fin des débats.
Les voix des députés
du Rassemblement National
et des Républicains
ont fait basculer
le scrutin.
40 élus de droite
ont voté en faveur
de la motion de rejet.
Face à cet échec,
la Première ministre dénonce
une alliance contre nature.
- Avec la NUPES
et le Rassemblement National,
vous avez refusé le débat,
mais le défi reste
et les attentes
des Français sont intactes.
Nous avons besoin
de solutions,
nous avons besoin
d'un texte rapidement.
Notre détermination
ne faiblit pas.
- Le gouvernement
a choisi de convoquer
une commission mixte paritaire.
C'est une réunion
de sept députés
et sept sénateurs
chargés de trouver
un compromis.
La majorité
ne peut pas y imposer
ses vues.
La droite se montre inflexible.
- Nous avons toujours dit
que nous défendrons jusqu'au bout
le texte du Sénat.
Tout le texte du Sénat.
Rien que le texte du Sénat.
- Attention,
trop de concessions à droite,
et c'est une partie
de la majorité
qui pourrait manquer à l'appel.
Si la CMP
est conclusive,
un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale
et au Sénat devra
valider le texte.
Si elle échoue,
ce sera l'abandon pur
et simple du projet
de loi immigration,
selon le président
de la République.
- Katia Gilder:
Annie Genevard,
avant de parler
de la négociation
de ce lundi,
on va revenir
en quelques mots
sur ce qu'il s'est passé
en ce début de semaine.
Coup de théâtre,
le rejet du texte
de Gérald Darmanin
par l'Assemblée nationale,
sans même un débat parlementaire.
C'est le principe
de l'adoption d'une motion
de rejet.
Une quarantaine
de députés LR a voté
cette motion de rejet.
Est-ce que vous assumez ce vote?
Est-ce que vous assumez
d'avoir fait
ce coup politique?
- Annie Genevard:
Ce qui a motivé
ce vote,
c'est d'abord le fait
que nous rejetions
le texte sorti
de la commission.
Un texte a été
adopté au Sénat
avec l'aval du ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Ce texte a été présenté
à la commission
des lois où je siégeais.
66% du texte adopté par le Sénat
a été modifié purement
et simplement.
Les mesures ont été retirées.
Ce texte était inacceptable
en l'état.
Nous avons déposé
notre propre mesure
de rejet.
Ce n'est pas la nôtre
qui a été tirée
au sort.
La démarche était la même.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les arguments défendus
par les Ecologistes
sont aux antipodes
des vôtres.
- Annie Genevard:
Ils veulent une régularisation
totale des sans-papiers.
Nous, Nous, nous demandons
exactement l'inverse,
c'est-à-dire un resserrement
des dispositifs.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle on a,
conformément
à la motion de rejet
qu'on avait déposée,
voté la motion
de rejet.
On a rejeté le texte
de la commission
pour revenir au texte du Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Mais en refusant
un débat sur ce projet de loi
à l'Assemblée nationale,
vous assumez
de ne pas répondre
aux attentes
des électeurs de droite
qui voulaient un débat
sur l'immigration?
- Annie Genevard:
Je voudrais dire
deux choses.
Le débat n'a pas été escamoté.
Il a eu lieu en commission
pendant 45 heures.
Ensuite, la motion de rejet impose
qu'un processus parlementaire,
qui est parfaitement classique...
On ne s'est pas mis
en dehors des clous
de la procédure
parlementaire habituelle.
Donc, le texte sera discuté
en commission mixte paritaire,
puis reviendra
dans les hémicycles
des deux assemblées.
Donc, nous...
Qu'est-ce qui a dicté
notre position?
C'est le fait que, précisément,
en voulant répondre
aux attentes des Français...
Aujourd'hui, près
de 7 à 8 Français
sur 10 disent
qu'il y a un problème migratoire
dans notre pays.
Les choses ne sont pas contrôlées.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une majorité
de Français
est favorable au projet
de loi de Gérald Darmanin,
avec un volet répressif
et un volet d'intégration
par le travail.
- Annie Genevard:
Quand les Français disent
qu'ils sont favorables au texte
de Gérald Darmanin,
il y a texte et texte.
Il y a trois textes.
Il y a celui
du gouvernement initial,
le texte adopté au Sénat,
et le dernier texte voté,
celui dont nous allons débattre.
Et puis, il y a eu
le texte examiné
en commission des lois.
C'est un peu compliqué,
mais il faut regarder
dans le détail.
Dans le texte adopté
en commission,
en réalité, il y avait vraiment
un relâchement complet
de tout ce que les Français
attendent
de leurs responsables politiques.
Ils
- Kathia Gilder:
Le gouvernement a convoqué
cette commission mixte paritaire
qui va se réunir lundi.
Sept députés
et sept sénateurs
vont devoir se mettre d'accord.
Dans cette commission,
il y a cinq parlementaires
de la majorité
et cinq de la droite.
Est-ce que vous pensez
franchement qu'un accord
est possible?
- Annie Genevard:
Alors, moi,
je suis d'un naturel optimiste.
Je pense qu'un
accord est possible.
J'ajoute que je pense
qu'il est souhaitable.
Il est très souhaitable.
Les Français,
précisément, attendent
de leurs responsables
politiques
qu'ils se mettent
d'accord pour répondre
aux difficultés du pays.
- Kathia Gilder:
Mais à quel prix,
un accord?
- Annie Genevard:
Entre 700.000 et 900.000 étrangers
sont en situation
irrégulière
dans notre pays.
Des demandes d'asile
s'emballent,
alors qu'à 70%,
ces gens
ne seront pas éligibles.
Il y a des OQTF,
des applications
de quitter le territoire,
qui sont réalisés
à moins de 7%.
Il y a plus de 500.000
étrangers
qui entrent
régulièrement
dans notre pays.
La situation dans notre pays pose
d'énormes problèmes
en terme de montée
du communautarisme,
de l'islam radical...
Tous les étrangers
ne sont pas des radicaux,
évidemment.
Donc, il y a besoin
d'un texte, d'autant
qu'il y a dans ce texte
des mesures répressives
qui visent à écarter
des étrangers représentant
une menace pour la République.
Il faut bien
comprendre
que ce que nous
avons fait,
ce n'est pas un coup politique.
Nous avons rétabli
un rapport de force
pour imposer au gouvernement
notre propre conviction
en la matière.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dans ce rapport
de force, en cas d'échec
de la négociation,
Emmanuel Macron a été très clair.
Il prononcera
l'abandon de ce projet
de loi.
Vous assumerez votre part
de responsabilité
dans l'absence d'un texte
sur l'immigration?
- Annie Genevard:
Normalement, en cas d'échec
de la CMP, l'examen
du texte reprend
au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée,
puis il y aura une nouvelle
commission mixte paritaire.
C'est ça, la procédure normale.
Dans la décision
du président
de la République,
j'ai approuvé
le fait qu'il convoque
très vite
la CMP.
Je pense qu'il faut
sortir très vite
de cette situation.
Maintenant,
quand il dit qu'il n'y
aura pas de texte, là, je pense...
- Kathia Gilder:
Il dit que si ça échoue,
c'est terminé.
- Annie Genevard:
Il met la pression
sur tout le monde,
et c'est très radical.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passera, alors?
Que dit-on aux Français?
On leur dit de circuler,
qu'il n'y
a rien à voir?
Ce n'est pas possible.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La négociation
se fera sur la base
du projet de loi
qui a été voté en novembre
par la majorité
de droite du Sénat.
Les sénateurs
Les Républicains
avaient ajouté
des durcissements
au texte.
La droite sénatoriale
souhaite les conserver,
mais certaines mesures
comme la restriction
de l'aide médicale
d'Etat figurent
comme des lignes rouges
pour la majorité présidentielle.
- Les négociations
se poursuivent
en vue de la commission
mixte paritaire.
Les LR maintiennent
une ligne de fermeté
et souhaitent
conserver le texte
du Sénat, plus ferme
que le texte d'origine.
Une des mesures
centrales porte
sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans-papiers
dans les secteurs en tension.
Pas question de toucher
à cette mesure,
pour la droite sénatoriale.
- C'est une ligne rouge.
On ne peut pas repasser
à un droit opposable
par les étrangers
en situation irrégulière.
Sinon, on fait passer
la politique migratoire
des mains de l'Etat
aux mains des passeurs.
- Faute de majorité en commission
mixte paritaire,
Renaissance est contraint
de faire pencher
le texte à droite.
Les députés
Renaissance ont défini
une liste de mesures
répressives
qu'ils refusent.
- Nous avons nos lignes
rouges,
des points sur lesquels
il est indispensable
d'avoir un accord
avec les LR,
sans lesquels
nous ne voterons pas.
- Le durcissement de l'accès
à la nationalité
ou la condition
de résidence de 5 ans
en France font partie
de ces mesures.
Le camp présidentiel
s'oppose à la polémique
de l'aide médicale d'Etat.
Le président
du groupe centriste
au Sénat se dit favorable
à un compromis.
- On a regardé
les points difficiles.
L'AME, par exemple.
On parle
de textes
qui n'ont pas leur place
dans le texte immigration.
On pourrait
considérer
qu'il y a un débat.
- Les LR et le camp
présidentiel
sont encore loin
d'avoir trouvé un accord.
En cas d'échec de la commission
mixte paritaire,
l'exécutif abandonnerait
son projet
de loi.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dans les points chauds
de la discussion,
il y a l'aide médicale d'Etat.
La droite sénatoriale
a voté une restriction
de cette aide
qui est touchée
par les étrangers
en situation irrégulière,
qui financent leurs soins.
Les sénateurs de droite
ont restreint
le panier de soins.
C'est unit ligne rouge
pour la majorité présidentielle.
Vous pouvez y renoncer?
- Annie Genevard:
De quoi parle-t-on?
L'aide médicale d'Etat
est une aide dévolue
aux étrangers
en situation irrégulière.
On parle bien de cela.
Donc, ça pose
la question de l'égalité
de traitement
entre les Français,
dont certains peinent
à se soigner,
et ceux qui n'ont pas droit
de séjour
dans notre pays
et qui accéderaient
aux mêmes droits,
sans avoir à cotiser.
Cela crée un problème d'équité.
Les Français
sont de plus en plus rétifs
à l'idée
que ce soit plus difficile
pour eux,
et que ce soit finalement
le même traitement
qui soit fait
pour les uns et pour les autres.
Il ne s'agit pas
de ne plus soigner
les gens qui en ont besoin.
Il faut bien comprendre
que personne,
dans cette question
difficile de l'AME,
ne dit "On refuse
de soigner,
on ne prendra pas en charge
les femmes enceintes,
les maladies graves,
les infections aiguës,
les vaccinations,
la prophylaxie", etc.
Simplement, on dit
qu'il faut restreindre
le panier de soins
à ce qui est véritablement
important,
et puis, il faut
que cette AME
ne soit pas un facteur
d'attractivité.
C'est ça, dont il est question.
- Kathia Gilder:
Alors, oui,
ça ne faisait pas partie
du texte initial
de l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
"un cavalier législatif".
Néanmoins, le débat
est ouvert au sein
du gouvernement.
Elisabeth Borne semble
évoquer une loi
sur l'aide médicale
d'Etat en janvier.
Est-ce qu'elle vous a donné
des garanties?
- Annie Genevard:
Oui, c'est une hypothèse,
effectivement.
Il semble
que cette disposition
soit un cavalier
législatif,
qu'elle n'entre pas
totalement
dans le champ
de la loi, et donc,
si on veut traiter
cette question,
il faudrait une loi spécifique.
C'est l'une des hypothèses.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous pensez
qu'elle verra le jour?
- Annie Genevard:
Je pense
que c'est indispensable.
Beaucoup de députés
conviennent
qu'il faut parler
de cette question.
Nous sommes des députés
ancrés
sur le terrain.
Je le répète, à 70%,
les Français disent
qu'il y a un problème.
Ca fait partie
des discussions
qu'il faut avoir,
mais en ayant
bien en perspective...
On a été
très caricaturés
sur cette disposition.
On a été accusés
de porter atteinte
à la santé publique...
Ce n'est pas le sujet.
Tous les soins
auxquels les Français
ont accès
par leurs cotisations
et par leur mutuelle,
ils ne peuvent
pas tous être donnés
inconditionnellement.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une révision
de l'AME
sur un autre texte,
c'est une hypothèse.
Autre point de discussion,
la régularisation
des travailleurs
sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension.
Vous pensez que la majorité
présidentielle peut accepter
la version plus stricte
de la droite sénatoriale?
- Annie Genevard:
C'est un des points durs
qui a motivé
le rejet du texte
de la commission.
Là encore, de quoi parle-t-on?
Nous ne voulons pas créer
une nouvelle filière d'immigration
illégale.
Les passeurs,
les mafieux de tous bords,
regardent notre droit
et regardent
par où ils peuvent
essayer d'organiser
des filières.
C'est par exemple les mineurs
non accompagnés.
Un mineur n'est pas expulsable.
On voit se multiplier
les mineurs
non accompagnés par milliers.
Dès lors qu'ils sont
dans notre pays,
ils vont pouvoir
ensuite,
grâce à la loi
Collomb, faire venir
leur famille.
Pour revenir
à la régularisation
des métiers
en tension, l'option
du gouvernement,
c'est de dire
que dès lors qu'on
a un travail,
pendant 8 mois,
sur une période de 24 mois,
et qu'on est résidant
en France
depuis 3 ans,
on peut demander
à être régularisé.
Nous, nous ne voulons pas
de régularisation
de droit.
Si on crée ce droit,
on crée un droit
sur le fait que tous
les étrangers
qui rempliraient
ce critère pourraient
être régularisés.
On a fait expertiser
les choses juridiquement.
Ce serait un droit opposable.
Le gouvernement a étendu
la mesure jusqu'en 2028.
Ceux qui ne sont pas
encore entrés
dans notre pays
pourraient, en répondant
aux critères
dans quelques années,
accéder à ça.
Nous refusons.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous pensez
que les députés
vont faire
un pas vers vous?
En commission des lois,
ils ont
émis
des critères de refus
de ces régularisations,
sur la menace
à l'ordre public,
à la polygamie...
- Annie Genevard:
C'est trop faible.
Les mailles sont trop lâches.
Il y avait trois critères
de veto:
la polygamie, la menace
à l'ordre public
et le respect des valeurs
de la République.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La droite sénatoriale
a durci le droit
du sol, l'accès
à la nationalité.
C'est une autre ligne rouge.
-
Annie Genevard:
Je ne vais pas vous dévoiler
les discussions.
Nous sommes en cours
de discussion.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous faites partie
de la commission
mixte paritaire
qui va tenter de trouver
un compromis.
- Annie Genevard:
Je participe aux réunions
qui sont conduites
sous l'égide
de la Première ministre.
Je ne vais pas vous dire...
Il faut être sérieux.
Il ne faut pas compromettre
l'issue
de ces discussions.
Je peux vous dire
que nous,
ce que nous voulons,
c'est que nous considérons
que l'accès
à la nationalité
est un acte très fort.
Il ne faut pas banaliser
l'adoption
de la nationalité.
Quand on accède
à la nationalité française,
ça veut dire
qu'on manifeste son désir
de participer, d'être membre
de la communauté nationale,
d'en accepter l'histoire,
les valeurs, l'avenir
en commun.
Ca ne se délivre pas à la légère.
Quand on a obtenu
la nationalité française,
on n'a pas le droit
de se comporter n'importe comment.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les LR veulent aller
plus loin que le projet
de loi immigration.
Vous proposez une révision
de la Constitution
pour organiser
un référendum
sur ce texte et pouvoir déroger
à certaines règles internationales
de Bruxelles ou fixées
par les traités internationaux.
Le texte a été retiré du Sénat.
Les centristes n'en veulent pas.
Pourquoi vous accrocher
à cette révision
de la Constitution,
qui n'a pas de majorité
et qui s'annonce lourd,
comme processus?
- Annie Genevard:
Il s'est passé
un événement
qui est très emblématique
et qui justifie
notre demande de réviser
la Constitution.
Vous avez vu que le ministre
de l'Intérieur
a expulsé un ressortissant
radicalisé
de nationalité ouzbèque,
et que le Conseil d'Etat,
la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme
ont ordonné à l'Etat
français de rapatrier
à ses frais
ce Ouzbek au motif
qu'il risquait
un traitement inhumain
ou dégradant dans son pays.
Dans ce pays,
il est précisément retourné,
alors même
qu'il était en France, réfugié.
Donc là, on voit
bien les limites
de la loi française.
Il faut réviser la Constitution.
Nous demandons trois choses.
1: que nous ayons
des plafonds migratoires,
des quotas.
Que la France
dise:
"Nous sommes en capacité
d'accepter
tant de personnes."
Le quota peut être à zéro,
d'ailleurs!
"C'est notre capacité
d'accueil,
de logement, de travail", etc.
Voilà.
Il faut fixer des quotas.
2: nous demandons que les demandes
d'asile soient faites
à la frontière,
pas forcément
dans le pays d'origine.
Ce n'est pas toujours possible.
En Afghanistan,
il n'y a plus de représentation
diplomatique de la France.
Les Afghans qui vivent
une situation terrible
ne peuvent pas demander
l'asile en France
dans leur pays,
mais à la frontière
de la France,
dans des représentations
consulaires.
C'est très important.
Les demandeurs
d'asile, à 70%,
sont déboutés.
A 90%, ils restent dans le pays.
3: nous demandons,
et c'est très intéressant
et très important,
ça nous permettra
de répondre
à cet exemple,
c'est que les personnes
qui représentent
une menace grave pour le pays
soient expulsables.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le projet de loi immigration
est présenté
dans un climat politique
très tendu sur fond
d'invectives
et de dérapages en série.
Jamais autant de sanctions n'ont
été distribuées.
Ugo Bernalicis a écopé
d'une sanction,
par exemple.
- Je vais demander
à l'Assemblée
de bien vouloir se prononcer.
Je demande
à ceux qui se prononcent
en faveur
de la censure simple
de se lever.
Brouhaha
Je vous remercie.
Je demande
à ceux qui sont contre la censure
simple de bien vouloir se lever.
Je vous remercie.
L'Assemblée a prononcé
la censure simple.
- Kathia Gilder:
Censure simple,
contre Ugo Bernalicis,
qui s'était mis
dans une colère
noire en commission
des lois.
Vous étiez apparemment
dans cette commission.
Est-ce que ce genre
de comportement
est digne d'un représentant
de la nation?
- Annie Genevard:
Non, c'est inacceptable.
Il était 19h40.
Il est arrivé en commission
en hurlant, véritablement,
à vous exploser les tympans,
en disant: "J'exige
que la commission
soit levée
pour que nous puissions aller
dans l'hémicycle."
A ce moment-là
se discutaient des textes
de La France Insoumise.
On était à 20 minutes
de la levée
des travaux de la commission.
Mais vraiment, il a hurlé!
C'était totalement
hallucinant, au point
que j'ai cru
que des députés allaient
en venir aux mains.
Ce n'est pas possible.
La sanction
est parfaitement justifiée.
On ne peut pas laisser
de tels comportements
se dérouler
à l'Assemblée nationale.
J'observe quand même
que le climat
est très dégradé.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dans ce contexte,
la gauche de l'Assemblée
nationale accuse
le ministre de l'Intérieur
d'avoir corrompu certains députés
Les Républicains
pour qu'ils votent
en faveur de son texte
immigration
en échange de la création
de brigades
de gendarmerie.
- Annie Genevard:
Moi, j'ai vu la création d'une
gendarmerie
dans ma circonscription,
dans le Doubs.
Voilà, mais je n'ai pas été
corrompue,
puisque j'ai voté
la motion de rejet.
Cette création
d'une brigade
n'a pas été le fruit
de tractations.
L'ordre a été donné par le préfet.
Il faut se garder des caricatures.
Maintenant, on sait comment
va la politique.
Il est possible,
mais ça a toujours existé...
Ce que je crois,
c'est qu'il ne faut
pas se livrer
à ce genre de choses.
On serait de la majorité
on aurait droit
à certaines contreparties,
et à l'inverse,
on serait dans l'opposition
et on aurait droit
à rien?
Je crois
que ce n'est pas conforme
aux usages républicains.
Il faut se garder des généralités.
J'ai donné
mon exemple,
pour ne pas
non plus affirmer
qu'il y a une corruption
généralisée.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci, Annie Genevard,
d'avoir été notre invitée.
A très vite.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA